So we're now really getting down to the core
of the argument that is becoming the argument
for Donald Trump and for the people that back
him up.
And many Republicans, which is we've got to
open up the economy soon.
We've got to stop the physical distancing
and a lot of places.
We've got to reopen business and for lack
of a better term.
This is what Dr. Anthony Foushee calls letting
it rip.
When when this was mentioned a week ago or
so feels like months ago, Foushee referred
to ending all of the provisions in distancing
and just letting the virus do what it's going
to do.
He referred to it as letting it rip.
More people will get the virus.
More people will die.
But the economy or really what is in Trump's
mind is the stock market.
Right.
But he's talking about the economy.
It might improve, but a lot more people are
going to die.
So fundamentally, when you boil this down,
especially when you look at who is is mostly
dying from the virus.
The question is how many grandmas, someone's
grandmas, how many of them are worth allowing
to die in order to save the stock market?
It's about older folks dying, mostly older
folks to save Wall Street and the stock market.
What is each life worth to different people
is essentially the question here.
How much economic downturn is justified based
on how many additional people will likely
die if we stop distancing and we reopen stuff
for days now?
Trump and people around him have expressed
an interest in ramping back up because they
don't want the cure to be worse than the disease.
As Donald Trump and Larry Kudlow and others
have started to say yesterday, Donald Trump
tweeted, quote, Our people want to return
to work.
They will practice social distancing and all
else and seniors will be watched over protectively
and lovingly.
We can do two things together.
The cure cannot be worse by far than the problem.
Congress must act now.
We will come back strong.
Then yesterday, during a Fox News town hall,
Trump floated for the first time a specific
date, which is Easter, Easter Sunday, April
12th.
Have to do that.
I'd love to have it open by Easter.
I would love to have it.
I'm sure I will.
I will tell you that right now.
I would love to have that.
It's such an important day for other reasons,
but I'll make it an important day for those
two.
I would love to have the country opened up
and just raring to go by Easter.
Now, this is insanely soon to even be thinking
about this.
Now, if you put a gun to my head and you say
Trump is deterrant, Trump's doing this on
April 12th.
No matter what.
How would you suggest that it be done in that
scenario?
If I were Trump, I would say, listen, I want
to do this on April 12th.
But in order to do it, I need your help.
I need all 50 governors, not 18, plus two
more doing partial stuff.
I need all 50 governors to shut down.
Stay at home order shelter in place until
April 12th.
Everybody's got to do it because remember,
30 states aren't doing a damn thing yet.
If Trump did that, then maybe you could partially
reopen on April 12th outside of hot spots
with older folks still staying home.
And again, this is like if you put a gun to
my head and you say Trump's doing it April
12th, how would you say he does it?
But this reminded me of a video of a young
guy who confronts economist Milton Friedman
decades ago on this issue of what's a life
worth?
How much should we spend or fail to earn for
go in earnings in exchange for each life?
It's a very utilitarian argument, almost psychopathic.
So so let's look at this.
Here's a guy asking Milton Friedman about
the Ford Pinto, the Ford pick.
Pinto's a vehicle that was very poorly designed,
many deadly fires related to gas tanks that
ruptured during accidents.
And Ford knew about it and they could have
prevented it with a $13 part on each car.
Let's look at this video clip that I have
just.
One more.
This has to do with the Ford Pinto.
I'm not sure if you're aware of the recent
revelations that have come out about the production
of that car.
Ford produced it, knowing full well that in
any rear end collision, the gas tank would
blow up because they had failed to install
$13 plastic block in front of the gas tank.
And Ford estimated in an internal memo that
that would cost about 200 lives a year.
They estimated further that the cost of each
life would be two hundred thousand dollars.
They multiplied and they found that the cost
of installing those blocks in each of the
cars would be more than the cost of saving
those 200 lives.
And over the past seven years, the car's been
produced and over a thousand lives have been
lost.
Seems to me that Ford did what would do the
right thing according to your policy.
And yet that seems to me to be very wrong.
So the kid lays it out there.
And here is how Milton Friedman responds,
which is essentially the calculation that
Trump and others are now starting to make
a very utilitarian calculation.
Well, let me ask you.
Let's suppose it would cost a billion dollars
per person should Ford to put a man on the
list.
Question now that you only argued tomorrow
night, the printer, you're not arguing about
principle.
Your no, no, no.
Because nobody can take the principle.
Nobody can accept the principle that that
an infinite value should be put on an individual
life.
Because in order to get the money involved,
in order to get the resources involved, it's
not money.
In order to get the research, they have to
come from somewhere.
So the kid says this cheap part could have
prevented all of these deaths.
And Friedman says, well, at what point would
it not be logical for Ford to spend the money?
Like, in other words, if it wasn't $13 per
car, but if it was a million dollars per car,
do you still force Ford to fix the car at
a million dollars per car?
And the conversation continues.
And here we are skipping ahead a little bit.
Bright.
Well, you are not arguing anything about principle.
You're just asking you are just arguing whether
Ford used $200000 was the right number or
not.
No, I'm not.
You suppose that would order?
No, no, no, no, no.
Those were two hundred million dollars.
What should Ford have done?
Hundred million dollars for what?
Suppose it would have cost 200 million dollars
per life saved?
Should Ford still have spent that 200 million
dollars?
You mean that's not that's not really the
question.
Yes, it is a question.
Yeah, that's the other question.
That's the only principle involved.
I don't know whether Ford did the right came
to the right or not.
Well, it's a question of whether these numbers
are valid numbers for the relative costs of
different things.
So this kid wants to focus on the question,
which is here.
We know $13 per car would have prevented all
of this death.
Milton Friedman says, what's the principle,
though?
Where is the line where we say this level
of expense to save a life makes sense.
This level of expense to save a life does
not.
And unfortunately, this entire framing is
logically fallacious.
And it's what Republicans and Trump are doing.
How many additional lives do we lose if we
reopen the economy versus the economic cost?
Are they mostly older people?
Are they mostly younger people?
How much is the life of an 80 year old worth
in economic terms versus the life of a 20
year old with many work years ahead of them?
And that's the implicit question.
But it's not this simple.
The question of what is a life worth to the
economy is a very different question than
are we willing to essentially sacrifice people
in their lives.
Because on some calculation made in Washington,
D.C., or to wherever Donald Trump is doing
these meetings, it's worth more to the economy.
But the reality is, the argument Friedman
makes is a fallacious argument.
Very often, economists whose views are those
of Milton Friedman will take these situations
to infinity to be able to defeat them.
The reality is that this is never the case.
Think about the Ford situation.
The idea of if it was to cost Ford a million
dollars per car to fix the Pinto, should they
still do it?
It's bogus because the Pinto costs thirty
five hundred dollars at the time.
That's the retail cost back in the 70s.
If the cost to fix the Pinto was a million
dollars, they wouldn't produce the car.
And that's why we shouldn't fall for these
two Infiniti nonsense arguments.
The kid isn't arguing.
Human life has an infinite value.
The kids arguing the life has a value that
is more than the $13 that it would cost Ford
to fix the Pinto in the same way.
Trump is calculating that grandma's life is
not worth what he believes the economy will
lose if he keeps the economy close and people
are bringing this to infinity.
It's not viable that we can't do this forever
and we can't do it.
Period.
Two to infinity.
But what we're talking about is a temporary.
Anomic slow down to save so many people.
The curves are the difference between a few
thousand dying, tens of thousands, hundreds
of thousands and millions of people.
This is one of the oldest economic arguments,
the pushing to infinity.
Trump is quickly getting his way on this and
a lot of people are going to die.
Now, I hope you're staying home.
And if you are and if you're looking for something
to do tonight, 8:00 p.m. Eastern is the David
Pakman Show Viewer Chess Tournament.
I am the 2019 champion because we had one
game.
I beat Pat at the end of twenty nineteen.
We now have a proper chess tournament.
We'll be playing tonight.
Follow me on social media for info.
I'll be streaming 8 p.m. tonight.
Join us.
Don't
miss it.